voilà on nous a parlé maintenant il faut
une Miss France plus féministe etc alors
je prends un raccourci mais dans le
spectacle je dis maintenant ça suffit
faut le dire en garde Miss France pour
voir des culs et si on va voir des
femmes intelligentes on regarde question
pour un champion mais mais je dis la
réalité un moment on est là pour élire
Miss France je veux dire c'est ce serait
pareil pour Mister France voilà on voit
toujours pour une plastique au départ je
m'en fous quand je garde Miss France que
elle a un bac + 12 ou 13 c'est je trouve
ça ridicule et hypocrite en fait voilà
vous allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
alors oui non oui non parce que là c'est
a il ouvre trop de leur mot euh un
travail ta maman apparemment apparemment
ça se tend les relations entre vous hein
ça saute
elle travaille tu crois qu'elle fait
quoi mais tu es con ou quoi ma mère elle
fait quoi alors tu crois qu'elle est
chez elle en train d'attendre que je
vienne faire à manger
j'avais un fils qui avait 19 Bentley je
travaillerai hein
vous êtes choqué par les propos de
Fabrice c'est honteux et alors sauf si
c'est de l'humour mais ça n'a pas l'air
le connaissant parce que je trouve ça
machiste
oui mais pas là je trouve ça humiliant
pour les miss moi c'est un spectacle
certes on peut l'améliorer c'est un
spectacle que je regarde qui représente
la France cracher dessus je trouve que
c'est du parisienisme misérable
est-ce qu'il a raison ou pas
il est super drôle ça fait du bien du
politiquement incorrect pour une fois
c'est une bouffée d'air frais et oui il
y en a qui regarde Miss France pour les
bonnes raisons et d'autres pour les
mauvaises raisons et c'est très bien
comme ça et je suis absolument pas
choqué alors juste moi je la vie de
Delphine quand même qui dit oui mais
elle Miss France elle dit oui voilà en
règle générale moi je le trouve très
très drôle là effectivement c'est de
l'humour et mais c'est pas politiquement
correct en ce moment dans les temps qui
courent
en fait la phrase plus appropriée serait
les hommes attendent le passage en
maillot de bain et c'est la même chose
que il peut se regarder des cuisses
on est désolé Delphine mais franchement
on ne lit pas la miss la plus
intelligente et on s'en fout
complètement de savoir
idiote on la regarde et si c'est une
bonne asse on est très content si elle
est moche la première partie c'est
effectivement que tout le monde attend
le passage en maillot de bain ça c'est
sûr mais entre deux nanas jolies je suis
désolé c'est celle qui parle le mieux et
qui est un meilleur discours et le
discours
non moi d'abord j'adore Fabrice j'ai
envie de tout le monde à aller le voir
en spectacle parce qu'il est très très
vite donc tu payes des places
j'invite à se déplacer en métro en RER
vous allez comme vous voulez non moi
j'aime beaucoup Fabrice sauf que je peux
pas d'accord avec lui on regarde pas
Miss France pour regarder des culs
aujourd'hui si tu veux regarder des culs
tu as plein de moyens avec ton téléphone
donc voilà moi d'accord
quand tu dis tu regardes Questions pour
un champion ça c'est marrant la vanne
est marrante merci beaucoup on a les
Miss France qui viennent ici tu l'étais
le premier à aller regarder en disant
ouais ça allait bien celle-là elle est
pas bien tu l'as tu dis pas
il dit quand elle parle elle dise tout
ce qu'elle veut te mettre ça elle
finisse tous chroniqueuse
il y a des femmes qui regardent Miss
France c'est pas capable pour les
mauvaises raisons alors oui non mais
pour moi c'est pas de l'humour il a
raison Miss France c'est un concours qui
a le culot de se prétendre féministe
alors qu'il réduit les femmes à leur
physique qu'il exclut toutes les femmes
parce qu'elles sont trop petites trop
grosses trop vieille trop moche trop
tatouer selon leur règle pour 2006 on
regarde Miss France pour se [ __ ] de
leur gueule ou pour se rincer l'oeil
donc il a entièrement bravo à me
connaître
alors juste
ça fait plaisir que tu es un peu lâché
Gilles Verdez
je ne sais pas si c'est de l'humour mais
je ne pense pas parce qu'il a quand même
dit que bon pour regarder des femmes
intelligentes il faut regarder où tout
ce qui est question pour un champion et
cetera et pour regarder Miss le concours
il faut en fait enfin c'est pour le cul
il prennent le cul ouvertement voilà moi
je veux dire si il veut si ça prend feu
en tout cas ça fait polémique machin on
laisse un peu de temps passer qui fasse
comme Will Smith ok il s'excuse et puis
je veux dire non non non mais c'est ça
quel dégage